lebkuchen tannenbaum weihnachtsmann und
eine poststelle für wunschzettel
so sieht ein typischer deutscher
weihnachtsmann aus wie hier in welche
doch woher kommen diese tradition genau
damit hat sich diese frau beschäftigt
claudia weingärtner ist autoren aus
münchen in ihrem aktuellen buch alles
mythos geht sie den ursprüngen deutscher
und europäischer weihnachtsbräuche nach
eine der zentralen fragen die vor allem
kinder beschäftigt woher kommt der
weihnachtsmann
ich weiß dass die rote farbe vom
weihnachtsmann auf jeden fall von coca
cola mit geprägt wurde
richtig ist dass das outfit des
weihnachtsmanns vom amerikanischen
illustrator hätten's hand bleiben
mitgeprägt wurde diese art 1935 die
weihnachtskampagne für coca cola
gezeichnet
der wohnort des weihnachtsmanns da sind
sich zumindest die filme sicher befindet
sich in rovaniemi mitten in lappland
2010 hat sich die kleinstadt als
offizieller wohnort des weihnachtsmanns
bei der europäischen union registrieren
lassen
der weihnachtsmann wurde auf keinen fall
von coca cola erfunden und kommt auch
nicht vom nordpol sondern es eigentlich
ein verwandter des heiligen nikolaus und
der nikolaus wurde von den niederländern
mit nach amerika genommen als die
ausgewandert sind zum teil und hat sich
ebendort der verweltlichten nummer zwei
ist weihnachten wirklich das fest der
liebe eigentlich ehren fest der liebe
aber ich glaube der stress kommt noch
zuerst mittel stressig und dann fest der
liebe nach einer studie herrscht bei 21
prozent der deutschen unter dem
tannenbaum dicke luft
hauptstreitpunkt ist neben
weihnachtsdeko und arbeitsaufteilung
auch die frage wo die feiertage
verbracht werden
seinen titel trägt das fest der liebe
dann aber doch nicht ganz umsonst
den neun monaten nach weihnachten kommen
wesentlich mehr babys zur welt als in
allen anderen monaten des jahres also
muss er doch was dran sein dass
weihnachten das fest der liebe ist
frage nummer 3 macht weihnachten und
dick auf jeden fall macht weihnachten
dick war immer wenn wir die sachen hier
sieht die haben alles schöne deftige
sachen mit drin
weihnachten macht nicht dick das sagt
zumindest eine britische studie
danach nehmen männer wie frauen nur etwa
400 gramm zu außerdem ist
weihnachtsgebäck ja sehr gesund weil
eben ihre inhaltsstoffe wie vollkornmehl
mandeln nüsse wahre kraftpakete sind die
auch dazu beitragen dass man über
weihnachten die nerven behält
frauen wollen schmuck und männer
wünschen sich technik so dass regel
klischee doch was steht bei den
deutschen tatsächlich auf dem
wunschzettel
laut einer umfrage der gesellschaft für
konsumforschung geben die deutschen
jährlich rund 290 euro für
weihnachtsgeschenke aus vor spielzeug
schmuck und technik stehen aber
überraschenderweise noch andere wünsche
auf dem wunschzettel
bei den geschenken zu weihnachten ist es
so dass es gute alte buch bei den
deutschen unterm weihnachtsbaum es sehr
beliebt ist also es muss nicht immer
schmuck für die frau und technisches
spielzeug für den mann sein
frage nummer fünf warum gibt es die
geschenke in deutschland am 24
dezember
foto kirche her ist es also jesus ist
ein anderes geboren habe also ich weiß
es nicht
in den meisten anderen europäischen
ländern gibt es die geschenke erst am 25
dezember die deutschen hingegen konnten
den heiligen abend einfach nicht
abwarten
eigentlich weiß keiner wann jesus
geboren wurde trotzdem haben sich die
kirchenoberen irgendwann dazu
durchgerungen und haben den
fünfundzwanzigster dezember festgelegt
nur ist es so dass in deutschland sich
die leute gerne die wartezeit bis zur
kirche in wirtshäusern vertrieben und
dementsprechend lustig ging es dann auch
in den kirchen zu deshalb hat die
obrigkeit mancherorts den gottesdienst
vorverlegt so wird der weihnachtsmann
die geschenke auch in diesem jahr
zumindest in deutschland pünktlich am 24
dezember unter den tannenbäumen
abliefern